you know I don't like identitarianism I
I've never been a fan of people who've
blamed everyone else for their problems
I remember doing Occupy Wall Street you
had people saying it was the one percent
that was the cause of their problems and
I'm like what are you talking about you
got one percenters here giving you money
you've got rich people down here
supporting Occupy Wall Street providing
funding you've got like George Soros
money going into these non-profits that
are funding you to complain about rich
people
it that the problem is is varying
agendas the problem is varying
ideologies the problem is everyone
fighting for power for what they want
in yay's circumstance they're coming
after him they're trying to take away
his stuff they're threatening them with
institutionalization and I understand
all of that it's unfortunate that he's
he's internalized this problem to it is
a it is a specific ethnic and religious
background that's doing it and I'm like
bro it's specific people doing it to you
you know what I mean yeah I don't know
what else to say